so thanks for coming my name is Max Anse
I'm pretty happy to be here in in Vienna
this is the first time for me and for
now I I really like the city so it's
really cool we can attack for I'm gonna
talk for the next hour about the the
progressive web apps yes all of my slide
everything this is my slide deck max
beautiful slash torch I'm gonna give
some some numbers etc so if you want to
check the source even if you want to see
back the slide after go go here after
you just need to select the correct the
quest torch which is a progressive way
but ok so this is the starting points of
of my torch months ago I read the I
start to find on the under on Twitter on
some blog posts we're talking about
native apps and are calling some people
they were doomed so I start to to dig
into into that and I find some
interesting studies interesting
statistic about it first of all
50% of the American user download 0 app
per month then only 10% download 1up
amounts and after one other 10% etc ok I
also find that most of the time we spend
on our smartphone is on the three on the
top 3 app and also as points it's more
about revenue it's pretty hard if you
are doing a native application to get
revenue from this if you are out of this
dispute also or the Google etc
there is another a problem if if your
company got an app it's art to to reach
people what I mean is an every step you
got on every step you are losing 20% of
the user so you have to find an app you
lost 20 user then you click on the
detail you lost 20 user etc etc etc so
at the end if you want to reach 1000
user at the end maybe 262 according to
this to D 262 it's it's an average but
gonna use the app and on this 262 this
studies say 5050 75% of the user don't
know Dan app use it once and never come
back on the day 2 we get we are more
than 80% TAC TAC TAC TAC until add three
months after or even yeah three months
after we got something close to 5
percent of the user we still use your
application the the reason is one of the
reason is sometimes we have to to
download an app and we don't really want
it when I came here in Vienna I had to
install the an app for four routes
fanzhen I think I'm just gonna use this
app once and look it's yeah he was
pretty similar or something like 14
megabytes just to show one QR code to
the yeah on the airport that's only why
I need an app for this after there is
some use case it still relevance about
about which ability also because of all
of this friction it's out for you to to
get new customers on the on your app
and under her Sahana a mobile with the
web it's pretty more simple to reach new
customers but that's you got synapse you
probably you probably know that the
users spend more time on the under
native app than a mobile application why
the answer is pretty simple you got
notification the user got already the
icon on the on the desktop so yeah there
is more engagement so let's summarize we
got two things we got the mobile app and
the website we with the mobile app we
can do a lot of things there is a lot of
capability etc but the reach ability is
really hard and here my web app I can
reach a lot of people but I cannot
retain them so some people must be from
Google they they start from from the
starting point and say ok how to put out
to increase the my website and get
something with more capabilities so
that's that the main yeah the main
reason to to you to switch to something
called the progressive web apps so we're
gonna try to put at the same level in
terms of functionalities a native app
unavailable
the progressive web apps it's just a set
of of correct rule that you web apps
have to add to reach so take care you
don't need to update your your LinkedIn
profile right now you probably do some
some of them the first one one of the
first rule is get links one page you got
one link
welcome to HTTP protocol something it's
pretty basic so I'm not gonna stay
longer on this slide I was talking about
HTTP we could add an S you recognize the
log here for years
people didn't switch to HTTPS because of
Mona is they did not want to buy a
certificate I have a good news since
2016 now there is something called let
some scripts and now this organization
provide free certificate no it's not
from hipster beatniks look there is a
lot of look this sponsor I mean we can
trust this okay the third points really
basic as well responsive you still don't
know what's responsive remember this
picture from Stephanie water
she said yeah content content is like
it's like water so don't want to put all
the data from this screen to the real
mobile
it's do something yeah responsive to
adapt to to to the device now we start
to reach something a bit more
interesting because you probably already
follow all this deserved yeah this three
step the first the fourth one is getting
something more applied so when you are
using a progressive web app you should
think about I am on the web I am on the
app now it should see it should be the
same experience there is something
interesting called the application
architecture so given I'm I'm a shop and
I want to to show some to show some
clothes judge that come did that day
cash the puts this and the left sorry
the left the red screen so all the
architecture cetera you keep it's it's
instant instantly loaded and then you do
a synchronous request to the network and
you go and you fetch the data on when
the data are air its feed the it it fit
the screen you got something pretty
similar if you are using Microsoft teams
it's an equivalent to to to slash there
is also this I think in in Facebook when
you scroll really really fast you just
see the architecture here also an
interesting study George don't come
reduce the the page load by 3.8 by using
this so it's something interesting you
the fifth points the fifth point is
getting something progressive there is
the framework I'm using which is called
with I'm using in my company is called
UGS and they say it's a progressive web
framework it mean you can use this you
can create some small component in this
technology in all fashion websites
without breaking everything etc so it's
kind of the same there is a lot of
diversity of browsers so if you want to
to add something fancy
in your browser it should not impact the
the whole browsers because yes
unfortunately not every border are the
same this is a Korean from Firefox
Firefox 58 so as you can see I cannot I
cannot do some Bluetooth USB NFC cetera
but if I check it with my Chrome here I
think I'm gonna get something slightly
different
yes I don't see yeah for instance this
and the back Bergeron sank etc it's not
the same in Firefox than in a in Chrome
the six points it's getting a fresh
application fresh buy fresh I mean
always up-to-date there is something
here a newer service workers I will come
back in this notion just after the idea
behind this is to get an application
always up-to-date Arish you see this is
my an app from my bank I updated four
days ago and they already asked me to to
do an update well sometime it's it's not
a big deal but when I need this app I
sometimes I just need it right now like
this is what I get the other day I came
back from from work and I just wanted to
to play to my race game and I got this
Korean say not today when air it's okay
it's 48 megabits but sometimes it's even
more and it's pretty annoying so the
idea behind this is to use something
called background sync to use some tasks
in background to update your app if you
are using some browsers like Firefox
Chrome it's they are working like this
you get an update and you just say Oh
next time you're gonna you're gonna
reload the browser we're gonna get you
can I get a new you're gonna get a new
new version but the that don't block you
so this is the idea
the seventh point is about installation
as I say before um something good with
your with native apps is you get the
icon on the screen so here the idea is
exactly the same you should be able to
get your web your web icon on screen
oops this is the progressive web apps I
did with this UGS framework and it's
based on the github API so I could eat
some kid verb if you see here there is a
small house with a plus so it's mean
it's a progressive web apps you can
install you can install this app so if I
click here I will get something like
this do you want to add this application
on your screen I click on add to add
screen and here I got it like this so
this is my phone you got two icon here
in the middle one from Firefox and there
was a one from Chrome and the difference
between this and the shortcut cause you
know some time you can just take a
shortcut
of the website and put it on your onion
on your home on your home page but here
it's considered by your own by urines me
your on your operating system as an
application which means I can after find
it if I want to find an application in
my phone there is also something so this
slide are progressive web apps friendly
which means I can also install them so
I'm on Chrome here and if I want to to
install my application wait
yeah I just need a click Add to Home
screen and it doesn't work oh no my bad
I didn't so look there is a at this
application to your shelf so you click
Add and my browser is well do more
effects
ok let's restart this ok inspect I go
application item screen hard ok I to add
to your desktop so here this is how it's
working a window and after I got
something pretty real here so I click I
say trust on lunch and tada
I got my slide and in slug-like it's
look like an app and look I can also
here put it on my on my dodge you've got
something pretty similar on OS X I
didn't test on on microsite on Microsoft
I didn't test it on Microsoft's so yeah
every every browser got a different way
of honoring this dismal house the the
install button I think in in Opera it's
on the left and also look like it's
there is also a plus in chrome you must
visit the page to time to get this yeah
that's it oh you might think okay it's
good oh can I get the displays button on
my on my website there is something
called
the manifesto JSON it's it's a web app
manifest and it's allow your application
to be discoverable so the web app the
JSON it's it's a file where you can put
some different some different
information about your about your your
web apps we get the name a short name
the short name is for the it's to put it
on the on the screen on the on your home
screen then you get a set of icons as
far I remember for Chrome you need an
econ with 500 pixels something like this
statue on its the and three-point
checkout
I put source equal on screen if you if
you check the spec of the of the web app
manifest they say you can you can do
this for analytics so after if you got
some Google Analytics or something like
this you can say ok I got 10% of user
using this these web apps from the
screen also display for screen if you
check on my web app on my when I when I
check just before the installation you
didn't so the you didn't so order the
panel from from the browser and mostly
the most important Eretz we don't see
the URL bar so which really looked like
an a real app from from your phone and
after you can put some background color
and Tim color I got another example here
so I'm still on Chrome if you want to
check your web app manifest on Chrome
you got the the developer tools and you
just go on manifest you will see the
name the shot name etc and the Add to
Home screen so if something is wrong
Google will that the tool will tell you
and say oh I cannot add it under screen
because of this disease so here I put
this some colors and I got all of my set
of icons something cool there is a lot
of website you just put one icon and
they generate everything including the
the manifesto JSON so it's pretty easy
to do also I was talking about Microsoft
I said I don't know all of did they
manage this but I got two good news
Microsoft want to crawl all the
progressive web app from the from the
web convert them into something weird I
don't know what is a PBX but after what
what they want to do is to to put them
in the Windows Store so as a real
application I think it's something
really cool but look I put a scientist
here so it's it's still in draft so we
have to wait they say 2018 so I think
but it was in September so I think we
have to wait something like six months
and after maybe we're gonna see some
application in the Microsoft Store so
here for to reach new customers it can
be pretty good another point to increase
the engagement with your customers is
the the notification you probably saw it
already in some website well sometimes
it's a bit annoying because when you
open a website say oh okay
can I send you notification so you
accept or decline and it looked like
this so you have to turn off on here
when I click I got some notification
from from the the operating system and
here say okay so you got you go to
notification from the application called
PWA this is the website this is a
message
and now the about connection because the
10-point the this point is about yes
making a websites offline because the
the best request is no requests it was
my face when I saw this I say whoa I
have to do a website offline yeah let
explain oh it's work
oh no before why why well we are in good
country with very nice internet
connection but unfortunately it's not
the same everywhere
so yeah in Austria it's pretty good I'm
working in Ireland it's pretty good too
but if you check in some country in Asia
in Africa in South America it's not good
well even in France it's one of the best
but I'm sure when my parent gonna see
this torque on YouTube they will not see
it in HD because you got a pretty pretty
bad connection and also something that
we have to keep in mind it's 45 % of the
world population it's still on 2g
network so we have to think about these
people it's very still people in in
Africa they don't know what the name
anand rate up and after they can give
them to each other in by USB so yeah
unfortunately not everybody got really
fast Wi-Fi so how does it work there is
something called serviceworker this is a
web page and the network something
really basic if you want to see the page
you do an HTTP GET to to the network and
something is coming in the in the
browser well it's already here but the
the document from the w3c is still in
draft but it's already implemented in
all the browsers
basically you got your webpage if you
want to exit to the network there is
something in the middle called a
serviceworker it's not only a proxy some
people resume a service worker as a
proxy but it's it can do much more but
the interesting part for from this point
is what we can do with the service
worker so I want to access to the
network and the service worker say oh I
saw this request maybe I can put it in
the cache so then if you want to get it
again
you just need to call the cache and all
of this is browser side when I saw this
I say wow it's pretty cool because now I
can do a lot of things in my in my
application Jake Archie bar wrote
something called the offline cookbook in
this offline cookbook in gave us some
some pattern from offline strategy this
one is sketch first you want to load a
page so first you ask to the Sudha cache
if there is no nothing in the cache then
you fall back on the network there is
another one it's the opposite its
network network first otherwise uganda
cache yeah for instance if i'm a shop
and i want to show the products i can
use this but maybe from a real sensitive
data like the price or the availability
maybe I want to do something like
Network only so no way you don't put
anything in the cache some more
interesting the cache then Network so
look I asked in parallel to the cache
and to the network the cash return me
the data and the same time I'm going on
the on the network and after I can read
through the data so while I'm navigating
on the website the data so first at t0
the data from the cache and after while
navigating the data are getting a to
date something pretty similar
it's my favorites its Stein while
revalidate you always saw the the assets
but from t minus one from the last time
you you were under on the website it can
be interesting for assets like
JavaScript files CSS etc so first page
the users so the when the user go in
your website is so the the result from
yesterday or for the last time you went
to your website and etc but if you got a
single page application maybe it doesn't
make sense but if you don't have a
single page application a web site like
Facebook usually you don't do only one
click you decide you reload the page
several times so on the first page you
get the version from yesterday maybe but
the page load instance only and on the
second page you get the some up-to-date
data so I gave you some huge strategy
for offline there is much more in the in
this website in this cookbook I
recommend you to take a look and yeah
you can also follow this guy check
Archie bar is pretty good guy from from
Google now how does it work or does it
work all of this oh oh I can do that on
my website this is some JavaScript code
basically everything is based on promise
but I don't know about you but sometimes
it can be a bit annoying to to write
very huge text huge huge code code just
to manage my assets there is something
called Warbucks Warbucks it's a pretty
good tour sponsored by Google by the way
and basically it look like this so on
the first parameter of this function so
so I defined some routes and I say okay
everything which look like PNG gif etc
all the image I want to apply cash for
strategy
I can also put some fancy name like the
name of the cache gonna be image you
honest or sixty six teenage and for a
duration of thirty days or if you want
something way more simple you can do
something like this here I want to store
all the HTTP calls from the github API
and then I want to apply the network
first strategy I'm sorry for you there
is no you have to deal with reg X so if
you are nuts
if like me you are not a big fan of reg
X it can be a small issue now let's
switch to the eleven points
single page application now I'm joking
and hopefully there is a lot of people
they say you have to be you have to
build a single page application to do a
privacy web apps it's wrong and it's
something pretty cool because building
and single page application is hard so
no single page application so let's
summarize this is my definition of a
progressive web app it's just something
really cool like this so you go to a
website under privacy web app but it's
not really professional so let's switch
to to another definition from Alex
reason another guy from Google which is
working on progressive web apps it's
saying it's a a PWA it's nothing else
than a website which take the good bit I
mean what are these good vitamin so
let's summarize it's something reliable
so HTTP you can get it even if you are
offline also it's fast thanks to the
service workers and you can get some
engage you can better engage the your
your customers with by installing the
application getting some what the name
notification etc another great tool to
help you to build the best PWA its
lighthouse lighthouse you get it by
default on chrome so I opened the dev
tools here and you get a pan core audit
and here you can click to perform an
audit you select what you want so yeah
let's select everything and light house
we scroll your website check about
performance or performance it is an 2g
network so blah blah blah and after it
will it will give you a report so here
I'm probably gonna blame me for the for
the performance because I got a lot of
image and I did not really optimize them
maybe your so again I complained for
some stuff because I put some CSS in
ditch it's not really nice but it's not
the goal do we need to wait wait so yeah
you can see what he is doing and here I
got my result here so I'm 64 compliance
with privacy web app so there is problem
because my application doesn't register
serviceworker I don't I probably break
something here you can also get some the
first meaningful paint this is really
interesting even if you don't want to
build a PWA you can get some good
insight from your websites say ok i have
to optimize this this to get a better
ratio something good with lighthouse you
can also put it in CRI so by using it
CLI its mean you can use it in your in
your pipeline your CI
CD etc and other points really important
it speed matter I like this picture this
is the team from Red Bull changing four
tires in two seconds while the average
page load on the 3G network is nineteen
second well nineteen second it's very
slow I don't know why well no we know
basically it's because of the analytics
non optimisation etc something you have
to keep in mind about speed if half of
the purse of the earth of the people
expect website to load in less than two
seconds and a few websites load in more
than three second yeah three second you
lost fifty percent fifty percent will
bounce so it can be something really
nice if you want to sell a PWR in your
in your company check the bounce rate
but unfortunately today there is things
that we still cannot do in your inner
progressive web app like I cannot access
to NFC to the calendar to my contact
list so we have to wait if you remember
the the screen from the screen I show
you about what the web can do it's
changing it's moving it's moving really
fast so I discover yesterday something
called the no not just today but few
weeks ago something called web payments
API there is a lot of friction today in
a in your application if you want to
sell something basically on my phone
there is something pretty good is when I
want to buy it's already linked to my
Google accounts it's pretty fast to buy
something on on a mobile on a memoir
mobile app but on the web you have to
take your wallet the credit card etc so
yeah to avoid this friction
developing this payment request API and
I think I did this in some really few
line of JavaScript you can get something
like this so here I give you a link if
you want to buy an iPhone for 10 euro
it's looked like this and I got
something from the browser here I got
the detail of of my bills here I can put
my credit card and I just need to click
on pay and that's it I don't need it so
I will not pay it also unfortunately the
user yet are not fully used to this to
this install button so I don't know
maybe in few years people will use this
but for now there is still a reflex to
go on the on the store so they have to
work on it if you check the first
version of the install button and what
is it today it change a lot so that
they're still trying to find the best
way to engage user through this this
button now the last part is about
feedbacks some company moved to the pro
se web app and they gave feedback to the
community
the first one is Twitter if you remember
the map I show you I show you in Africa
for instance there is no the network is
pretty low company like Twitter want to
keep this market and want to better
reach this market so they create
something called Twitter elite it's it
just Twitter but you in a HTTP request
you just take what you need to so the
there is less less less more requests I
think the the full on page only took one
way one megabit one megabyte to load
it's much more for the other app
um yeah we did this up afters is the
Texan matrix um it's pretty interesting
to see that because the app is better
there is better performance on the with
the browser etc so the user use more
applications 65% it's a lot so and also
people people use more upset with more
they come back more often the 20% also
fob did something pretty similar as a
switch to PWA plus 100% engagements it's
pretty good it's well it's awesome the
user use more the application yeah you
got the the source it's also on
developers.google.com it's a really good
resource to switch to bwa or to get some
insight from company that switched to
PWA so it's yeah the developer blog from
Google and also the last one is what
Pinterest did Pinterest from it's the
the most most important study from from
them so they say okay let's go to PWA
and they realize that people stay more
and up they consume more they get more
money because they are Bazin they use
advertising fortunately unfortunately
for us there is more engagements and
after they also did something
interesting they compared the statistic
from the native app and from the web app
and they realized that it's kind of the
same so if you remember at the beginning
I was showing you this diagram so today
we're here it's in the same level it's
not in the same level to be wholly
honest but it's changing a lot there is
a lot of improvement from the browser
it's changing fast so maybe yesterday
you did not want in a native app for
some reason but now you can do
it's because your web apps can access to
your positions your localization you can
also buy a new mobile etc so keep an eye
on keep an eye on these websites what
web can do that today
etc because yeah it's moving it's moving
really fast
thank you I think I got time for some
questions ya know so your question is is
it possible today to be in the in the
application store application store you
mean the Android store and the iOS one
for now the reasons for is no there is
nothing already check the only thing is
plan is from the Microsoft Store to put
PW way after I think there is a reason
there is a reason why they didn't talk
about it it's also because because you
have to follow some rules Li for the I
think the iOS for iOS the scan or the
scroll your your application etc and
follow for a web app it's a bit harder
to to check what's inside and so for me
it's it's the reason after maybe it's
gonna change I don't know any other
question
so if it's the end the question if it's
if it's the end of the native app well I
don't have my crystal ball
some people say native apps are dooms it
was the introduction I truly believe
that today the progressive web app on in
few years they're gonna get challenged
mmm
does it still relevant today to build to
build native apps yes for some companies
it's they're making all of the demo a
year after also some event some
application they were only on on native
apps and this switch also to web apps
like tinder the switch to PWS there is a
nice blog still on google and are giving
some insight
so people so people are switching to to
this because there is a need I don't
know if if it's going to get replaced
mmm from my point of view yes but I'm
pretty and not very good for predictions
yeah also puts if you check on on this
slide I put some some tools or also
there is one color PW a builder they
help you to generate your manifest there
is what webpagetest.org to measure the
performance of your website
yeah also oh yeah you are asking if it's
to relevance the native apps it wasn't
my backup slide this is the trend from
from Facebook so the world go on mobile
so yes it's relevant to still building
native apps but PWI from it's also been
interesting because the the mobile on
the web it's still the same it doesn't
decrease
okay yeah well I think you can so it's
when here so your question is what's the
website about your privacy right so if
there is - I think it's there yeah you
got it in Chrome settings so you can see
here for instance your web app can
access to your geolocalization without
asking you I was a bit scared when I saw
this I say well they can check a lot of
things yes your GPS localization she
doesn't need to ask you they can access
it directly so err the notification by
default here I are oh but you can also
block them but the most important things
to watch is what you can get by default
so yeah here the camera
well not here the location it's the
default so they need to ask maybe it was
on Firefox it's by default I don't
really remember so yeah after you have
to some stuff are our blocks for some of
them they are low by default so you have
to keep an eye on it but yeah something
good also with your native apps you know
what what they need is a transfer to a
question yeah yeah I think it's okay for
that time maybe a quick last question no
it's okay okay thank you very much
[Applause]